hey guys it is Thursday my name is Jeff
I'm Dan first up we've got a heap of
destiny to news for you ahead of the
curse of a cyrus expansion Bungie has
outlined what to expect as part of their
two major updates they have and they've
also commented on the recent XP scaling
controversy let's talk about that XP
situation first
over the weekend a reddit user found a
silent system the scaled XP earned from
some activities basically if players
completed something like public events
in quick succession the XP amount earned
from each success would slowly diminish
this was particularly notable as post
level 20 any levels earned reward
players with a bright and Grahm
decimeters version of a cosmetic loot
box once the system came to light Bungie
quickly disabled it but increase the
amount of XP required to earn a bright
Engram post level 20 from 80,000 XP to
160,000 Bungie has now offered an
explanation for the situation saying our
intention was to keep slower paced
activities as rewarding as high
intensity grinding without confusing
variations in displayed XP values but
the silent nature of the mechanic
betrayed the expectation of transparency
that you have for destiny to work has
begun on changes to the system with
Bungie pledging to be more transparent
and quote link these internal and
display only values together for greater
consistency and to ensure that when
changes are made they are accurately
reflected everywhere we report them now
that's out of the way as part of the
same blog post Bungie also outlined what
to expect from the two title updates
that will arrive on December 5th and
12th the first patch on the fifth which
arrives alongside the curse of Osiris
expansion makes changes to armor mod
components legendary engrams and
reputation tokens AMA will now have
equivocal ornaments that will change the
look of certain ARMA sets without
changing shaders and mods each armament
set will have a set of objectives to
complete to unlock its ornament
account-wide the gunsmith will now sell
specific legendary mods for legendary
shots and mod components and dismantling
rare mods will result in gunsmith
materials and a chance of producing
legendary quality mode components you'll
also be able to pick up legendary
engrams from the cryptic in the game's
social space December 12 we'll see the
major changes to destiny - with
addition of masterworks versions of
legendary weapons which trap kills
create orbs on multi kills and have
reroll about random stat bonuses
masterwork versions of weapons can be
obtained through drops post power level
250 while existing Legendary's can also
be upgraded to masterworks weapons
obtained from raids and trials of the
nine have a very high chance of being
masterworks versions of gear also as
part of the update most faction vendors
will sell faction armor and weapons for
legendary shards and tokens with weapons
rotating weekly everyone's favorite
wispy bearded creep yeah sir we'll also
get a new item in the form of faded
engrams which decrypt into exotics you
don't already own the three of coins
will also return which boosts exotic
drop rates for four hours it's enough
destiny for now
next up Bandai Namco have revealed a new
buy here at academia game called my here
at academia ones justice a teaser
website has arrived which currently just
shows a grenade rolling out of a
microwave with the text three days left
Japanese manga publication Weekly Shonen
Jump confirmed that the game exists
however and will be coming to Nintendo
switch and PlayStation 4 no other
details have been revealed as yet but it
sounds like we'll hear more when the
game's first trailer drops on December
16th the last of my here at academia
game battle for all came out for 3ds in
2016
finally Rockstar Games parent company
take 2 which made a bunch of money off
microtransactions has said that guess
what loot boxes aren't gambling thriving
so surprising during a Credit Suisse
event take 2 president Kyle slide off
weighed in on the loot box controversy
that's currently gripping the industry
he explained we don't view that thing as
gambling our view of it is the same as
the ESA statement for the most part so
potential legislation is going to play
its course in terms of the consumer the
noise you hear in the market right now
it's all about content and over
delivering on content he went on to say
it's about making sure you're focused on
engagement and I think that's been our
strategy as long as you keep your eye on
the ball you're going to be ok the
consumer is going to be really happy
with what they get GTA online recently
had its best quarter ever in terms of
microtransactions revenue which is
pretty impressive for a full year old
game that's everything we have for you
today enjoy the rest of your day and
please do let us know what you cared
about in the comments below
yes and do remember we'll be back same
time tomorrow with our thoughts
the biggest stories from this week so
come by let us know what you think and
something else a third thing but I've
got it I've got two things
yeah